our speaker today is Dr Nigam Shah and
we're very very excited uh that he was
able to join us today
um Dr Shah is Professor of Medicine by
medical informatics at Stanford
University associate uh CIO for data
science at Stanford Healthcare and a
member of biomedical informatics
graduate program as well as a clinical
informatics Fellowship his research
focuses on combining machine learning
and prior knowledge in medical
ontologies to enable use cases of the
learning health system and with that I
will hand it over to Dr Shah thank you
thank you Stacy welcome everyone
and today what I have planned is uh a
little bit of an overview of why such
the course that we're talking about
exists and the key issues that are
typically not covered when we're talking
about Ai and Healthcare and so hence the
subtitle Thinking Beyond the model which
is sort of a catchphrase to remember
that you know yes it's important that we
talk about the technical things that on
how to build models and algorithms but
at the same time in order to get
anything out of them in terms of its
value for improving care we have to
think a bit broader and that's what
we're going to focus on uh today so
let's get started
so one of the most useful things I can
share with you is that typically when we
talk about data we're talking about
tables and text files and images and so
on but the most useful view that I've
found of patient data is this timeline
view
so on screen is a patient Journey going
from left to right shown by this Arrow
the little circles on there are events
of medical consequence that have
happened
and that's not how we store data so this
is an abstract object that we think
about when we're thinking of data each
individual item might be stored uh uh in
in a different location but when a
clinician thinks about data we're always
thinking about what happened when what
happened after that what happened after
that and so on
and then when we start diving into the
kinds of things that come to us when
we're building models
those data take the form of these
different tracks that I've overlaid
underneath that Arrow there could be
medical claims information
there could be codes like ICD CPT and so
on medication orders procedures lab
tests and their results clinical notes
textual documents along with them uh
signals from bedside monitors signals
from variables that are consumer grade
devices we might have some molecular
data and then as we get more fancy we
might have you know phone usage and
browsing history and social media data
and so on
you could imagine
you know 50 60 perhaps 70 such tracks of
information
and as we think about these data and
let's call let's name this thing let's
call this a patient timeline object
two things remain true
there is nobody who has a complete
longitudinal track on a patient for any
given modality
and there's nobody no entity not even
the patient not provider insurance that
has all the modalities at any given
point in time for the patient
so we're dealing with a very high degree
of fragmentation
that these things reside in multiple
locations in multiple data systems but
when we think about them and using those
set data for improving health care we
have to think about this entire patient
timeline object
so then
what do we do when we use these data to
provide better care so let's work with
an example meet Laura who's a teenager
with systemic lupus erythromatosis she
has protein urea is pancreatitis and is
positive for this Laboratory test of
anti-phospholipid antibodies in her
blood
and the treating physician in this case
and this is a true case happened on our
campus around 2010 time frame uh the
treating physician needs to make a
decision
about whether to use anticoagulation as
in Heparin uh for such a young
individual because they're worried about
the risk of Laura developing blood clots
and having the Deep wind thrombosis
basically clotting your leg
so what do we do with the data
so we start out with all patients
in those patients we find those that are
pediatric as an under 18. we find those
that have systemic lupus so that's uh
you know this thing here we find those
that have antiphospholipid antibodies
those that have protein urea
and then we overlap all of them to find
this little ellipse here you know my
drawing is bad with the mouse so it
didn't turn out to be exactly an ellipse
um
that then gives us
these set of patients that meet all
these criteria
some of whom developed blood clots these
are these red dots that I'm putting on
right now and then there are others that
had
all of those things
um and phospholipid antibodies and
develop the blood clot and then what we
would be looking at is this rate of
these blood clots in these two sets of
patients and trying to ascertain the
risk of our patient having that problem
and then if the risk is high enough we
would then uh use uh anticoagulation in
the form of Heparin so there's two
things going on here actually three
things thing number one is assessing the
risk
which tells us whether to act in this
case the risk is of having those blood
clots
then there is the threshold which is
kind of implicit like what is high is
the risk of two-fold high or 14-fold
high that's usually left as a judgment
call
and then there is the what to do
in which case here it is quite clear
that if the risk of the blood clot was
high enough we would have used a a blood
thinner like Heparin or anticoagulation
so those are the three things going on
but from a data standpoint
as we go from these timelines
to models the things that give us these
risk estimates for example
to the decisions what's happening
underneath is we have these multiple
timelines and I'm just showing three of
them
which we will then manipulate and
convert into a data Matrix
sometimes paying attention to time
sometimes ignoring them so we just have
a flat Matrix so to speak a table rows
our patients columns are their
characteristics also called features
on that we will train some model
and then that model is going to guide
the decision of whether to treat in this
case we're talking about having the risk
of a blood clot or how to treat in which
in this case we didn't have a a question
about that we would have used Heparin
but often you need to learn that from
the data as well
so that's the journey we're on
and why does this journey matter
because the majority of the time and
this might be a shock to a lot of you uh
on in the audience is that we're
deciding without data
so this is a little bit of an extreme
example from Pediatrics which happens to
have the least amount of uh of uh
prospectively collected evidence but in
this particular study when they observe
the decisions made over a scan of seven
and a half days about 158 decisions per
day were made and eighty percent of them
were deemed by physicians to have no
basis in any prior published data
and about three percent of of them were
based on a specific study that was
relevant to the question at hand
that is how bad things are
now if you think about it
the decisions that the physician makes
are now recorded in electronic Data
Systems ehrs and others
so the idea would be why can't we go
back to those same data
do this exercise of converting them into
a data Matrix building a model to guide
our decisions of whether to treat and
how to treat
and there's tons of work out there on
how to do that there's lots of classes
you can take from engineering from
computer science on Coursera and what
have you that will teach you how to
build a model basically how to go from
say an image over here to a model that
outputs a number like basically getting
you up to this stage
but what next that's what we're talking
about today
so to ensure that
Healthcare AI is useful
we do have to pay attention to the model
and its output 100 percent
but in order to get
useful reliable and fair AI guided here
what we also need is to pay attention to
the policy meaning at what level of our
risk estimate are we going to do
something
and what is our capacity to do that
thing
you know drugs you can imagine are an
unlimited Supply like statins and
heparin and so on but if we need to do a
biopsy or if we need to do an MRI scan
or so on the capacity to do so is
limited and then that puts a hard limit
on the number of actions we can take
and then often many things in medicine
also come with harms and so we have to
worry about the properties of the
intervention itself is it going to lead
to more harm than benefit and we always
want to make sure there's more benefit
than harm as in the net benefit is
positive and then all of these three
things interplay
and we have to pay attention to all of
them
so in in the current conversation I'm
going to give you a few examples uh and
then we'll open it up for uh for a
dialogue
so we've been working on this on our
campus for I would say the past five six
years uh there's multiple faculty
members involved in in a large
collaboration that has led to over 15 or
so Publications on various aspects of
how do we get to useful reliable and
fair AI guided care so let's uh double
click and go in down into one of them
so we're talking about this capacity
constraint issue and usefulness so we
build one of these dashboards that is a
real thing if you go to this particular
URL you will find a dashboard uh don't
hit on it too hard it is still a student
prototype
um
there's two concepts going on here on
the left is a classic
plot called the Au Roc sometimes also
called the the receiver operator code
which is the full form and we're
plotting here the true positive rate
against the false positive rate for a
particular model
an equation that is giving us a risk
estimate and this black line is uh is
sort of the quantifying its performance
that how often does the model identify a
patient at higher risk to be above a
patient at low risk that's what that
thing is telling us
and then there's classic methods from uh
economics that estimate the utility
of taking an action at a certain cut
point in that so that would be this red
dot right here
and then we can draw this little line
again very standard math that tells us
that what are the what are different
points of true positive false positive
rate that would have equal utility so
till then standard stuff
the thing we're doing new is overlaying
this green zone
which is that given our capacity to do
something given the algorithm's output
what part of this plot is feasible or
achievable for us
now it's really hard to visualize that
in this left side plot in its standard
rendering so we came up with this other
plot which is on the right hand side
where we're just ordering the positive
Cases left to right going from those
that have very high probability to very
low probability
and then on the y-axis we're just
plotting the unit utility that we might
be getting by taking a follow-up action
on them
and as we March down the list you know
from the highest risk case to the next
to the next to the next and so on uh
we're just tracking how much cumulative
utility we're getting so it's just a
different way of looking at the
information on the left hand side and
this tells us that we're only going down
the list about this much
meaning word capacity constraint and we
would have to go a little bit further
all the way to here if we want to reach
maximum
and so that gives us a a quantification
that we might have a very good model
but if we don't have the capacity to
follow up on its recommendations and go
down this list we're not going to get
any use out of it and so that's
usefulness under capacity constraints
another big issue that comes up is how
do we make sure that these models are
that are used to guide decisions are
fair
so there's two parts to this
part one is uh is the model or that
equation producing a number
that is equally good or equally bad for
everybody and that's what we're looking
on this plot so what the model gives is
the predicted probability we have some
ground truth and here the the image is a
little bit pixelated but what we're
looking at is how close is the model's
prediction to ground Truth by
male female
black white
and what we want to make sure is at the
decision boundary so in this case this
is the probability at which we were
going to do something
and we want to make sure that for all
the classes of Interest all the
subgroups of Interest add the decision
boundary the predicted probability
matches
the true probability
and this is called calibration and you
know here's the URL for considerations
and reliability In fairness audit of a
model or predictive model in this case
for Advanced Care planning which is the
use case that we've been working on on
our campus for several years now
so this is part one is the model
behaving the same way for everybody
part two
is
the model might be behaving perfectly
but then it's the humans who take action
in response and there's various humans
various stakeholders in taking the
response so on this uh you know plot
that looks like a dart board the model
is here
and then there are patients there are
providers as in doctors there's
insurance companies that are Patient
Advocates that are nurse practitioners
administrators everybody has different
concerns
and the question then is how do we
evaluate these ethical concerns with
applying machine learning to guide
Advanced Care planning and this is uh
coming out shortly
the point being that if the values of
the stakeholders
are not aligned we might have the
perfect model
but it is not going to give us
Equitable care and it is necessary to do
such analysis up front so that's sort of
the the two-part message on how do we
make sure Healthcare AI is fair
and then last I'll touch on how do we
make sure that Healthcare AI is reliable
now that also has two parts
sometimes it manifests as explainability
or transparency or interpretability and
those are the different words that are
being used
um I broke the I break this down into
three uh categories so there is this
notion of the engineering
interpretability in the sense that
what is the mechanics of how a model
produced the output like the underlying
mathematical formulation and you know
what are the weights being transmitted
and how what are the features or the
data elements the model is relying on
that's the engineering interpretation of
real interpretability I'm sorry
and knowing that gives us some
information to decide is this
model reliable
but then there's two other aspects to it
there's the causal nature of
interpretability in the sense that
why did a certain input produce the
output
so I'll give an example
you can have
a model an algorithm that you train on
patient information
which can come up with a silly sounding
conclusion that says those men who have
white hair or are bald have a high risk
of a heart attack
that's a true Association
from an engineering standpoint I can
even explain the weights behind that
particular uh observation
but from a causal sense
Whitehead have very little to do with
the with the uh getting a heart attack
and it's it's just a confounding a
confounded finding just happens that
older age you tend to have white hair or
you might have you might be bald and at
that point your risk of heart attack is
higher
so from a causal interpretation
standpoint that model is completely
useless even though it's risk estimate
might actually be fairly accurate
in another situation we have this thing
called the pooled cohort equation that
looks at blood pressure cholesterol
diabetes and so on in order to produce
the estimate of having a heart attack in
that case the interpretation of that is
causally valid
and then the third thing is often a
clinician would ask for interpretability
in order to make the decision that can I
trust
this particular AI this algorithm or
this model and so it's a surrogate for
trust now trust can be established by
other means you know if we if we look at
the 4900 or so FDA approved drugs
a lot of them we don't have the faintest
idea how they work
but we have established that they do
work by performing a prospective
randomized control trial
so when we think about how to ensure
that Healthcare AI is reliable we have
to unpack whether are we talking about
the engineering interpretation
are we ex are we requesting a causal
Association or a causal finding because
that is necessary if you want to take
some mitigating action in the example
we're using painting somebody's hair
black that's not going to change their
heart attack risk but lowering their
cholesterol certainly will and so in
that case it does matter you know what
is the causal mechanism
and then if the need is to establish
trust uh there are some very interesting
findings from Microsoft research that
sometimes an explanation of providing
explanation leads to higher than
necessary trust and the and the users
fail to spot the mistakes of the model
it's an elegant series of experiments
where they've shown that if you're shown
a model to predict the price of an
apartment and then you're given the
engineering explanation you will fail to
spot the mistake of a model trying to
price an apartment which is like 700
square feet and has four bedrooms and
five bathrooms which is like logically
impossible uh but because the model is
explainable people will tend to trust it
so there's some goofy things that can
happen if we don't unpack these three
Notions of reliability
and then there's a second at part to
reliability which is is the decision
making done being done based on the
model getting us the outcomes we want
so for example
on the x-axis here we have some
percentage of the population receiving
intervention let's say prescribing
statins in the case of a heart attack
risk
and on the y-axis the number of outcomes
desirable outcomes uh obtained for
example preventing a heart attack
if we do things at random which is here
50 of the people will get a Statin and
it will work about half the time
and then we can have this thing called
this line which is called the burrito
Frontier where we say all right what if
our AI was
such that the it had demographic
parodies and it worked the same way for
people of all Races and ethnicities all
right maybe it's still a little bit
better than random but it's only working
about
accomplishing about 92 percent of the
outcomes
if we maximized utility well fewer
people will get the intervention and we
will get more desirable outcomes
and so we can examine these trade-offs
to answer the question are we getting
what we bargained for uh when we use
Healthcare AI
all right so all of this that I just
shared with you in the past couple of
minutes it's informed by experience from
the front lines uh we've been working on
this uh project for using machine
learning or AI to empower Advanced Care
planning we've used it to power a team
driven workflow uh it's out in the New
England Journal Innovations and Care
delivery
that's what we're doing to push the
frontier
and then in in doing so we've figured
out a process which again I see here is
quite pixelated uh for building Fair
useful and reliable models which is what
we were just talking about in the last
couple of slides and then in parallel
we're also building
an ml Ops team in the it organization of
the health system so that we can do
these things to improve the care of
patients that come to us and all of
these experiences would go into this
course where it's Project based would be
working on real data sets that
building models and then figuring out
how we're going to use them and work
with them so I'll pause there and stop
here and we can open it up for questions
all right so we have some questions
coming in and everybody this is also the
time to submit your questions as well
but
um let's get started
um so we have a question
um can you go a little further in depth
on an example of ensuring the usefulness
for AI models being used in Stanford
Healthcare
example the problem how you assessed it
and how it's currently being used
so I'll just work with this Advanced
Care planning example so here it is very
well established through prospective
randomized control trials that patients
who are at the uh near their end of life
they benefit from having this
conversation about goals of care which
is what are what is your desire for how
care should be managed when uh things
are not going that great
it's called Advanced Care planning
the the the challenge is that most
people
think of doing that conversation too
late
so ideally this conversation should
happen about a year in advance but it's
very hard to identify who's going to die
in one year
and so before our project began the
majority of these conversations were
triggered in the last 30 days of
somebody's passing
it's too late
and our estimates and again these are
research estimates from other studies
are there about seven to eight percent
of people in a hospital
would be truly benefiting from this
Advanced Care planning conversation we
just don't know who they are
and so we build an algorithm to flag
patients
which based on historical data their
care pattern looks like they're at high
risk of dying in the next three to 12
months
we don't show that probability to
anybody because the probabilities is a
predicted estimate but what we use that
to do is those that are at high risk get
put on a list that is flagged to the
clinician that they should undergo this
conversation about Advanced Care
planning
so there's a special team that does this
now that team's capacity was limited
they could do say maybe five a day and
you know we have 100 patients get it
that get admitted every day
and on any given day maybe there's 20
maybe there's 15 that need to have this
conversation
so that's where this collaborative team
comes in that we trained multiple people
the nurse practitioners the residents
the medical students the social care
worker
to be comfortable initiating this
conversation
and as a result
we're now increasing the rate at which
the eligible patients have this Advanced
Care planning done and the goals of care
documented so that when things are you
know getting exciting like in the movies
where things are happening in the ICU
and the patient is not in a position to
to to say something uh their fi their
true wishes are honored and the and the
care provided is concordant with their
goals
and then we track the rate at which the
uh Advanced Care planning and goals of
care are being set up and we're hovering
we used to be at very low level single
digits you know just with everybody else
so to speak and now we're consistently
hovering at 15 follow-through rates as
in the the top lit part of the list
always gets followed up within a
conversation happens
all right
um so the next question we have is
actually
um how are AIML models received by top
top doctors
um I'm curious about how experts use or
likely to use the machine
um in chess tournaments where humans are
allowed to use chess
um engines GMS with good chess engines
tend to lose to average players with
good chess engines
um I'm wondering if there is a
correspondent Dynamic at play here
so there's an excellent question uh it's
in some sense it's all over the place
um and it in some sense it depends on
how you define the the term machine or
the model
so I'll give a couple of examples to
illustrate
um if you if we agree that an algorithm
is any routinely repeatable procedure
that stands in place of a human being
and produces a readout we've been using
AI in healthcare for like 15 years or
more maybe 25 years
so when I trained in med school uh in
order to get this simple thing called
the CBC the complete blood count or
differential blood count
we would put a drop of blood on a slide
smear it put it under a microscope and
with a counter just like you would see
at an entrance of a game or something
like I'd be looking through the
microscope counting how many white blood
cells did I see and were there
lymphocyte and you know neutrophil and
whatnot
today we put a drop of blood in a
machine which shines a bunch of lasers
out comes a printout that says you know
neutrophil count is this and 20 this and
30 percent that and so on so now we have
an algorithm that has completely
replaced a human
in obtaining the CBC
if you think of that as a machine or as
a model
doctors rely on it entirely I would not
want to do a CBC myself manually because
I will be less accurate than a machine
at any given day
now if we take the lens that an
algorithm is something that is alerting
so for example this Advanced Care
planning work that we're talking about
in that case
most doctors our first question would be
like can you prove to me that this
actually works and you're not wasting
mind the patient's time
and then once you do the hard work of
convincing them that what is being
identified and presented to them
for follow-up are indeed the patients
that they would want to follow up with
then they adopt it
and then there will be a huge huge slew
of use cases that fall somewhere in
between and in order to fully dissect
how is an export going to be using the
algorithm you do have to understand the
downstream workflow and we're in the
process is the algorithm fitting is it
replacing a human being is it augmenting
a human being is it interrupting and
stopping a human being and then what is
the degree of autonomy that we're going
to Grant to the algorithm is the
algorithm such that it will read some
data and prescribe something well you
know maybe people are not ready to
accept that but if an algorithm is
reading a blood draw and then producing
a bunch of numbers that a human
interprets were already there so that
hopefully gives you a range
all right
um and we actually received another
question uh which is uh what specific
medicine areas or uh Specialties could
at the midterm future get the best from
AI
again very nice question
um it depends on what source you consult
for that answer
if you consult the popular media you the
answer will most likely come in the form
of Imaging radiology and pathology
if you consult insurance companies the
answer will come back mostly in the form
of a automated claims processing and
ensuring billing integrity
not the top of Mind things for most
clinicians
and so I think I would be the uh the if
you if we restrict our uh question to
what medicine areas
even there is going to be a bit patchy
so for example Ophthalmology is already
there they have an FDA approval for an
algorithm that can autonomously read a
retinal scan and charge 85 no human is
in the loop and it diagnoses diabetic
retinopathy
um
and then on the other end of the
spectrum are is like detecting sepsis in
the ICU where there's hundreds of models
out there hundreds if not 500 600 and no
Clarity on do we even get reliable value
out of it uh you know there's some
studies that have shown uh that in
certain settings in certain hospitals
you can get value from them but not
always
so as a very crude heuristic I would say
if we limit AI to neural networks
anything that has pictures Radiology
pathology Ophthalmology Dermatology
Cardiology also in some case is going to
likely to be the one that hits the
headlines
in terms of the ones in terms of the
areas where the use of algorithms even
simple algorithms like logistic
regressions and and predictors that
impact the largest number of human
beings to improve their care it will
most likely be in population health and
back office operations
all right thank you so much
um we have another question which is
about I think a more reliability and
data missing so in healthcare you have
situations when there is
but there's also situations when the
data is simply missing or not there not
available so how do you proceed in terms
of analyzing this type of data which is
just not there and is there a way to
fill in those blanks or do you have any
suggestions for how to approach those
kind of situations so missing data are a
very active area of research and as a
heuristic you know on a webinar where
we're looking for a a high level true
answer uh I can't go into a in-depth
analysis of missing data but I would say
if if the degree of missingness is small
I'm going to pick 10 right uh there are
many
algorithmic ways to impute and overcome
it assuming you have lots of other data
set other patient data where it is not
missing you can there are techniques out
there that we can impute
if the degree of missingness is high and
let's say I'm going to say you know if
it's 70 missing it's a high degree of
missingness
uh we need to teach the algorithms to
abstain and say look these data are so
sparse I cannot give you a prediction
so that would be my suggestion on how to
tackle this and of course for any
specific use case there'll be various
nuances of what can be imputed when can
you be imputed the one thing I would
caution uh for sure is that standard
techniques of imputation from the
engineering disciplines are likely to
backfire
for the very simple reason that in
medicine when things are missing could
mean two things that it was supposed to
be present and is not
or it wasn't needed and therefore not
collected
so for example in my medical record you
will not find a troponin c measurement
but if you look at all other males about
my same age and take the ones that have
a troponin measurement match based on
age and other things and then impute a
value for me you will get an abnormally
high value
for the very simple reason that there
was a human who decided to collect
troponin measurements in those other
individuals and there was a human who
said who decided that it is not needed
for me
and so you have to proceed with
imputation a little bit carefully when
you're working with real world data uh
you cannot make the assumption that when
a value is absent it was supposed to be
present so let me go ahead and impute it
you have to identify those cases where
somebody made a choice that this is not
necessary and therefore did not spend
the money to collect that information
all right thank you
um another question that we received was
uh you mentioned using medical
ontologies how are they currently being
used in AI models
excellent question so they're usually
used behind the scenes uh so when you
have data we were talking about that
patient timeline and they come from say
multiple sources and some of them might
be coding in ICD-9 and those are ICD-10
so when you have to do those
translations you might have drugs that
are sometimes coded in like India ndi is
sometimes an RX Norm
um so doing all of those translations
and mappings from one data set to
another is where the ontologies are used
most commonly
and then as we go into the the the
building of classifiers they're also
used to collapse the feature space so
that for example you can feed in a drug
Knowledge Graph
and and collapse all anti-hypertensives
into one column in your data Matrix
um so those would be the two broad
places where they're used to clean up
the data and translate between various
vernaculars of the same thing and then
when you're processing the data you and
you have two sparse of a data structure
you can make it dense by using the graph
structure of an ontology
all right thank you and
um another question is what percentage
do you think could be potential
generalization of the models um at all
the world
uh patient level so that's a that's a
very interesting question and I have a
very non-standard take on it
um
I see no reason
for a readmissions model that works at
Stanford
in Palo Alto to also work in Mumbai in
India
like expecting that generalization like
what is the scientific basis by which we
require such generalization
so what happens there typically is we
overlay the thinking that comes from the
science of medicine onto these
operational work
where that expectation is just unfounded
so for example if I'm building a
predictor for heart attacks based on
physiological inputs cholesterol blood
pressure you know what's my blood
glucose and smoking status and so on I
100 expected to work between here and
India
but if I'm building a readmissions
predictor that is dependent on how
Insurance works and you know what are
the social determinants of health and
income levels and housing and
transportation access
why would I even have the expectation
that my models will generalize to Mumbai
so I don't think that models should be
required to generalize in all settings I
think that is a misguided expectation
from the community at this point
all right great
um and then another question is which
from the healthcare space must be the
person in charge to leave the deployment
of AI in healthcare institutions
so that depends on the anatomy of the
healthcare Institution
um
the way to think of it is that what is
the minimum set of stakeholders
and then at the minimum
you want the person who is going to be
affected by the model's output as in the
recipient of the prediction
the person who is collecting the data
that is going to be fed into the model
and the model builder like these three
stakeholders are the absolute minimum
and then if you if you expand the circle
a little bit you would want who is the
decision going to impact so the patients
the providers uh you know perhaps your
Finance people
uh and then
the people who are tasked with filling
the data asset because you might have
the analyst who's extracting the data
for you but you if you start depending
on a certain data stream you definitely
want to have a uh have dialogue with the
people who are filling that data stream
or collecting the data stream so you can
understand all the nuances that go into
it so I'll start with three as the bare
minimum and then expand as your
organizational Anatomy requires
all right thank you and um is there a
field or subject that Ai and health uh
Healthcare cannot or should not be
applied uh to
I don't think we can make any blankets
claim like that uh in terms of a subject
area or a field I would say we should be
looking for situations
where it would be unethical
or technically impractical
to apply algorithm guided decision
making and and those vary Case by case
uh so we we have this one slide on how
do we make sure AI is fair there was
that dartboard kind of map which is a
stakeholder analysis like that readout
would tell you that there's so much
value mismatch and what people want from
these things that are in this particular
situation that we shouldn't do it like
that's the way to ask instead of a
blanket statement that never use it for
mental health or something like that
all right great
um
and
what are the best practices to assess uh
transferability of algorithms to
different settings
so transferability is is in my mind
another word for generalizability and I
would say why would you want to transfer
a readmissions model from Stanford to
Mumbai
so I think the the most important best
practice is to ask the question is
transferability even a valid expectation
and we have some research out there that
shows that instead of expecting to
transfer the algorithm
we should work to transfer
the process of learning that algorithm
to another setting
so share recipes instead of the final
dish
all right great
um and also um another question and I
think we're coming to uh an end to our
question so if anyone has any more
questions this is the time to submit
them now we do have a little bit of time
and might be able to cover them all
um but another question is
um when thinking about collecting data
especially in healthcare it feels a
little messy uh since there are so many
types of potential data that you can uh
collect
um and analyze
um how do you suggest approaching the
different types of available data and
kind of getting the most results out of
it including potential handwritten or
um doctor notes
as well so I mean there's two ways to
answer this I will answer it in the
practical way
like once you've analyzed this use case
in terms of can a model and a model
guided decision making be useful in a
certain setting
the first thing I would try
is to use the data that are easily
cheaply and consistently available
to see if they're sufficient
for getting a good enough model
to have the impact you desire
is there any practical way to think
about it instead of asking the question
in order to build the best model what is
the universe of data I need to collect
and then find yourself in a situation
where you know five or ten of those data
elements are such that are truly
expensive to collect
I would ask the question given what you
have at your disposal
what is the best model you can build
that accomplishes the goal at hand
so flip it on its head when you're
trying to assess data adequacy
so much and also thank you everyone for
uh submitting wonderful questions
um we have more questions coming your
way Dr Shaw so
um what level do you think the low
interpretability would allow the
development of AI in healthcare
so you know I I I have blogs out there
uh tinyurl.com forward slash do not Dash
explain which gives you a hint as to
what my position is on this and it of
course unpacks all of these things about
causal and engineering and Trust
inducing
um
I think if we rush to adopt AI without
establishing Trust
then this lack of interpretability will
backfire for sure
I think establishing trust establishing
uh fairness and establishing usefulness
I think are way more important than
interpretability
and interpretability is a crutch to get
to those things and there are other
direct ways to get to fairness
usefulness and reliability and that's
what I would suggest focus on that
thank you
um and I think this also a question that
came in which is a very interesting
question too
um have there been any examples of using
AI or machine learning during the
covid-19 pandemic and uh if so how has
it played a part in treating patients um
and impacting Public Health
so I would say in the covet pandemic AI
has been a complete and utter letdown
I mean I'm not going to mince words on
that there are studies uh systematic
reviews from a group in the UK it's in
the bmj journal unfortunately I forget
the uh the authors Dr Moon m-o-n is one
of the authors but uh there's like 15 28
co-authors where they have an ongoing
systematic review of all of the
different models that people have built
to help the pandemic or medical decision
making during the pandemic and most of
them are such seriously flawed that I'm
glad they were never implemented
all right
um
and uh just a few more questions that
came in and I think uh one is uh
clarification question actually
um when Dr Shaman should transfer
recipes from one setting let's say
Sanford to another setting let's say
Mumbai
um are you referring to data cleaning
prep and model hyper parameters in that
sense
um I'm not sure I follow that one
uh when I'm talking about
transferability I'm talking about taking
an algorithm let's say for Simplicity a
logistic regression that is trained at
one site and let's say it has 10
features and then certain weights it has
learned and then flunking it into
another site where we expect the same 10
features and have the belief that the
weights are still valid
all right great and I think also um in
terms of the previous question uh what
level do you think the low um there is a
clarification they were not referring to
in uh interpretability they were
referring to in Terror parability oh
interoperability uh yeah sorry it might
be my accent so
um interoperability is sort of the often
ignored can of worms uh in healthcare
and it will definitely impede the
development of good algorithms in
healthcare
uh and it manifests in many forms so if
if we go back to the patient level that
timeline if some of those data reside in
different Health Systems who cannot
transmit it to my home health system so
to speak or my primary care provider
that lack of interoperability leaves
gaps in that longitudinal record and so
then it increases the level of
missingness which makes it harder to
learn good models
uh and so interoperability if we don't
solve for that we would be we will be
limiting ourselves to only building
those models that can be built from the
local data at hand and I don't have a
good estimate but will definitely not be
realizing the full potential of AI in
healthcare in easily less than 50
percent uh is what we will be within
reach if we don't solve for
interpretability
or interoperability
all right great uh thank you so much
um and I think with that we can get
ready to wrap up
um so any kind of final remarks uh Dr
Shah or things to keep in mind for
audiences
from your end
you see that again do you have any final
remarks or things that our Learners
should uh or participants in the session
should keep in mind
um after this webinar yeah so I think
the main sort of macro takeaway is that
there's this beautiful slide of you know
first released uh in a paper uh by
researchers at Google research that
shows so the universe of things that
need to happen in order for a model an
algorithm to give value to any business
any business process I think what they
the title of that paper is hidden
technical debt in machine learning
systems or something of that nature
and
the the figure which is uh you know now
very widely known shows that the
algorithm aka the model is a tiny tiny
part of the overall system
10 or less
is the rest of it how do you acquire the
data how do you clean it up how do you
ensure that it is consistently updated
how do you ensure you get it at the the
time latency that you need in order to
produce the the model output what is the
downstream workflow how often is it
triggered what is the capacity all of
those things
matter way more than the model itself
and so the the suggestion to the the
audience is that do not over index
on how to build the model the
engineering of it
it's a pithy way of saying that is that
computer scientists or Engineers will
think uh about have I built the model
right
whereas informatics practitioners will
ask the question how we build the right
model
then focus on the right model instead of
building the model right
look outside in all of the different
parts of the workflow in which the model
is one Cog of that of that massive uh
Rube Goldberg machine and and and see
the implications on everything else and
that is going to be a stronger
determinant of the usefulness and
acceptability of your AI than anything
else
all right thank you so much
um so thank you uh Dr Shah for uh
joining us today and hosting the webinar
and of course thank you everybody for
joining and being with us and for all
the wonderful questions that came in
um I want to just quick reminders for
the end
um
please make sure to check out our
website and all the relevant uh programs
uh which are the AI uh professional
program Ai and Healthcare program by Dr
Shah as well as our new machine learning
and projects Health projects and
Healthcare course
um check those out apply enroll and we
hope to see you in some of our courses
and uh future webinars
um as well thank you so much everybody
once again and this is not a goodbye and
this is a see you later hopefully
thank you